The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so let's
get started.
I want to talk mostly about
countable state Markov chains
today, which is the new topic
we started on Wednesday.
I want to talk just a little bit
about the strong law proof
that was in the third
problem of the quiz.
I'm not doing that because
none of you understood
anything about it.
I'm doing it because all of you
understood more about it
than I thought you would.
And in fact, I've always avoided
saying too much about
this proof because I thought
everybody was tuning them out.
And for the class here, it looks
like a lot of you have
tried seriously to understand
these things.
So I thought I would explain
that one part of the quiz in
detail so that you'd see the
parts you're missing, and so
that [INAUDIBLE] all these other
proofs that we have,
talking about the strong law
and the strong law for
renewals, and putting them
together and all of these
things, all of them are
essentially the same.
And it's just a matter
of figuring out
how things fit together.
So I wanted to talk about that
because it's clear that most
of you understand enough about
it that it makes sense.
The situation in the quiz, which
is very close to the
usual queuing situation and
little theorem type things,
there's a sequence
of Y sub i's.
They're IID.
There's the service times for
G/G infinity queue, and n of
t, which is a renewal
process for the
arrivals to the process.
We have arrivals coming in
according to this renewal
process, which means the
[INAUDIBLE] arrival times, X
sub i, were IID.
And we want to put those
two things together.
And we want to find out
what this limit is.
If it's a limit, show
that it's a limit.
And hopefully show that it's
a limit with probability 1.
And I think a large number of
you basically realize that
this argument consisted
of a bunch of steps.
Some people with more
detail than others.
But the first step, which we do
in all of these arguments,
is to divide and multiply
by n of t of omega.
So we're starting out, looking
at some particular sample
path, and start out by
multiplying and dividing by n
of t of omega.
The next thing is to claim that
the limit of this times
this is equal to the limit of
this times the limit of this.
Almost no one recognized that as
a real problem, and that is
a real problem.
It's probably the least
obvious thing
in this whole problem.
I'm not saying you shouldn't
have done that, because I've
been doing that in all
the proofs I've been
giving you all along.
It is sort of obvious
that that works.
And when you're constructing a
proof, especially in a quiz
when you don't have much time,
things which are almost
obvious or which look obvious,
you should just go ahead and
assume them and come back later
when you have time to
see whether that really
makes sense.
That's the way you
do research also.
You don't do research by
painstakingly establishing
every point in some
linear path.
What you do is you carelessly
as you can and with as much
insight as you can, you jump
all the way to the end, you
see where you're trying to go,
you see how to get there, and
then you come back and you try
to figure out what each
of the steps are.
So this is certainly a very
reasonable way of solving this
problem, because it looks like
this limit should be equal to
this limit times this limit.
The next step in the argument is
to claim that this sum, up
to N of t of omega, over
N of t of omega, as
t approaches infinity--
the argument is that t
approaches infinity--
this N of t of omega goes
through, one by one, a
sequence, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, and so forth.
So this limit is equal
to that limit.
I've never been able to figure
out whether that's obvious or
not obvious.
It is just on the borderline
between what's obvious and not
obvious, so I'm gonna
prove it to you.
And then the next step is to see
that N of t of omega over
t is equal to 1/X-bar
with probability 1.
And this limit is equal to
Y-bar with probability 1.
The first argument, this equal
to 1/X-bar is because of the
strong law with renewals.
And this one over here is
because of the strong law of
large numbers.
And most of you managed
to get this.
And the whole argument assumes
that X-bar is less than
infinity, and Y-bar is
less than infinity.
Now, how do you go back and
actually see that this
actually makes sense?
And that's what I
want to do next.
And if you look at this, you
can't do it by starting here
and working your way down to
there, because there's no way
you're going to argue that this
limit is equal to this
product of limit unless you know
something about this and
you know something about this.
So you really have to establish
that these things
have limits first before
you can go back
and establish this.
In the same way, you have to
know something about this
before you can establish this.
So what you have to do way after
you've managed to have
the insight to jump the whole
way through this thing, is to
go back and argue each of the
points, but argue them in
reverse order.
And that's very often the way
you do research, and it's
certainly the way
you do quizzes.
So let's see where those
arguments were.
Start out by letting A1 be the
set of omega for which this
limit here, N of t of omega over
t, is equal to 1/X-bar.
By the strong law for renewal
processes, the probability of
A1 equals 1.
This is stating this in a little
cleaner way, I think,
than we stated the strong law
of renewals originally,
because we started out by
tumbling together this
statement and this statement.
I think it's cleaner to say,
start out, there's a set of
omega 1 for which this
limit exists.
And what the strong law says is
that that set of omega has
probability 1.
And now we have some terminology
for A1, what it
actually means.
It is the set of omega
for which this works.
You never have it working
for all omega,
only for some omega.
Then the next step, let A2 be
the set of omega for which the
limit is n goes to infinity of
1/n times the sum of Y sub i
of omega, is equal to Y-bar.
By the strong law of large
numbers, the probability of A2
is equal to 1.
So now we've established there's
an A1, there's an A2.
Each of them have
probability 1.
On A1, one limit exists.
On A2, the other limit exists.
And we have two sets, both
at probability 1.
What's the probability of the
intersection of them?
It has to be 1 also.
So with that, you know that
equation three is equal to
equation four for omega
in the sets, A1, A2.
And also, you know that
the probability of A1,
A2 is equal to 1.
So we've established this part
of the argument down here.
Now we want to go up and
establish this part of the
argument, which as I said, I
can't convince myself that
it's necessary or
not necessary.
But since I can't convince
myself, I thought, in trying
to make up solutions for the
quiz, I ought to actually
write a proof of it.
And I want to show you what the
proof is so that, if it's
not obvious to you, you'll know
exactly how to do it.
And if it is obvious, you can
maybe sort out exactly why
it's obvious.
So this is an epsilon delta
kind of argument.
We assume that omega is in A2.
That's the set for which
the strong law of
large numbers holds.
There exists some integer, n,
which is a function of both
epsilon and omega.
This is the funny thing
about all of
these strong law arguments.
In almost all of them,
you're dealing with
individual sample paths.
When you start saying something
exists as a limit,
you're not saying that it exists
as a limit for the
random variables.
You're saying it exists
as a limit for a
set of sample paths.
And therefore, this epsilon here
that you're gonna choose,
you need some integer there,
such that this minus this is
less than epsilon.
I think I'm going to have
to give up on this.
These things run out of
batteries too quickly.
So we have that this difference
here must be less
than epsilon if n is bigger than
that m of epsilon omega.
That's simply what
a limit means.
That's the definition
of a limit.
The only way to define a limit
sensibly is to say, for all
epsilon greater than 0, no
matter how small the epsilon
is, you can always find an
n big enough that this
difference here is less
than epsilon.
Then if omega is also in A1, the
limit of N of t of omega
has to be equal to infinity.
If you want to, you can just
say, we proved in class that
the limit of t of omega is
equal to infinity with
probability 1, and introduce
another set, A3.
You want to do a
probability 1.
But let's do it this way.
And then there has to be a t,
which is also a function of
epsilon and omega, such
that N of t and
omega is greater than--
that's an integer, by the way.
That's greater than or equal to
m of epsilon of omega for
all t, which is greater
than or equal to t
of epsilon of omega.
That says that this difference
here is less than omega.
And that's true for all epsilon
greater than 0.
And that says that, in fact,
this limit has to exist.
This limit over here is equal
to Y-bar with probability 1.
So that's what we were trying to
prove here, that this limit
is the same as this limit.
So we found out what
this limit is.
We found out that it exists with
probability 1, namely on
the set A2.
This is equal to this, not
necessarily on A2,
but on A1 and A2.
So we got into there.
Now how do we get the fact that
this limit times this
limit is equal to the limit
of [? these. ?]
Now we have a chance of
proceeding, because we've
actually shown that this limit
exists on some set with
probability 1, this limit
probability 1.
So we can look at that set and
say, for omega in that set,
this limit exists and
this limit exists.
Those limits are non-0 and
they're non-infinite.
The important thing is that
And we move on from there,
and to do that carefully.
And again, I'm not suggesting
that I expect any of you to do
this on the quiz.
I would have been amazed
if you had.
It took me quite a while to sort
it out, because all these
things are tangled together.
Where am I?
I want to be in the
next slide.
Ah, there we go.
Finally, we can interchange the
limit of a product of two
functions--
say, f of t, g of t--
with the product
of the limits.
Can we do that?
If the two functions each have
finite limits, as the
functions of interests do for
omega in A1, A2, then the
answer is yes.
And if you look at any book
on analysis, I'm sure that
theorem is somewhere in the
first couple of chapters.
But anyway, if you're the kind
of person like I am who would
rather sort something out for
yourself rather than look it
up, there's a trick involved
in doing it.
It's this equality right here.
f of t times g of t minus ab.
What you want to do is somehow
make that look like f of t
minus a, which you have
some control over, and
g of t minus b.
So the identity is this is equal
to f of t minus a times
g of t minus b--
we have control over that--
plus a times g of t minus b,
plus b times f of t minus a.
And you multiply and add all
those things together and you
see that that is just
an identity.
And therefore the magnitude of
f of t times g of t minus ab
is less than or equal to this.
And then you go through all the
epsilon delta stuff again.
For any epsilon greater than
0, you choose a t such that
this is less than or equal
to epsilon for t
greater than the t epsilon.
This is less than or equal to
epsilon for t greater than or
equal to t epsilon.
And then this difference here
is less than or equal to
epsilon squared plus this.
And with a little extra fiddling
around, that shows
you have that f of t, g of t
minus ab approaches 0 as t
gets large.
So that's the whole thing.
Now, let me reemphasize
again, I did not
expect you to do that.
I did not expect you to know how
to do analysis arguments
like that, because
analysis is not a
prerequisite for the course.
I do want to show you that the
kinds of things we've been
doing are not, in fact,
impossible.
If you trace them out from
beginning to end and put in
every little detail in them.
If you have to go through
these kinds of arguments
again, you will in fact know
how to make it precise and
know how to put all
those details in.
Let's go back to countable
state Markov chains.
As we've said, two states are
in the same class as they
communicate.
It's the same definition as
for finite state chains.
They communicate if there's some
path by which you can get
from i to j, and there's some
path from which you can get
from j to i.
And you can't get there in one
step only, but you can get
there in some finite
number of steps.
So that's the definition of
two states communicating.
The theorem that we sort of
proved last time is that all
states in the same class are
recurrent or all are transient.
That's the same as the theorem
we have for finite state
Markov chains.
It's just a little hard
to establish here.
The argument is that you assume
that j is recurrent.
If j is recurrent,
then the sum has
to be equal to infinity.
How do you interpret
that sum there?
What is it?
P sub jj, super n, is the
probability that you will be
in state j at time n given
that you're in
state j at time 0.
So what we're doing is we're
starting out in time 0.
This quantity here is the
probability that we'll be in
state j at time n.
Since you either are or you're
not, since this is also equal
to the expected value of state
j at time n, given
state j at time 0.
So when you add all these up,
you're adding expectations.
So this quantity here is simply
the expected number of
recurrences to state j from time
1 up to time infinity.
And that number of recurrences
is equal to infinity.
You remember we argued last time
that the probability of
one recurrence had to be equal
to 1 if it was recurrent.
If you got back to j once in
finite time, you're going to
get back again in a
finite time again.
You're going to get back
again in finite time.
It might take a very, very long
time, but it's finite,
and you have an infinite number
of returns as time goes
to infinity.
So that is the consequence
of j being recurrent.
For any i such that j and i
communicate, there's some path
at some length m such that the
probability of going from
state i to state j in m steps
is greater than 0.
That's by meaning
of communicate.
And there's some m and
some pji of l.
Oh, for [? some m. ?]
And there's some way of getting
back from j to i.
So what you're doing is going
from state i to state j, and
there is some path
for doing that.
You're wobbling around,
returning to state j,
maybe returning to
state i along the way.
That's part of it.
And eventually there's
some path for going
from j back to i again.
So this sum here is greater
than or equal.
And now all I'm doing is summing
up the paths which in
m steps go from i to j, and
those paths which in the final
l steps go from j back to i.
And they do whatever they
want to in between.
So I'm summing over the number
of times they are in between.
And this sum here is
summing over pjjk.
And that sum is infinite,
so this sum is infinite.
So that shows that if j is
recurrent, then i is recurrent
also for any i in
the same class.
And you can do the same thing
reversing i and j, obviously.
And if that's true for all
classes that are very
recurrent, all law classes that
are transient have to be
in the same class also, because
a state is either
transient or it's recurrent.
If a state j is recurrent,
then the
recurrence time, T sub jj.
When you read this chapter or
read my notes, I apologize
because there's a huge
confusion here.
And the confusion comes from
the fact that there's an
extraordinary amount
of notation here.
We're dealing with all the
notation of finite-state
Markov chains.
We're dealing with all the
notation of renewal processes.
And we're jumping back and forth
between theorems for one
and theorems for the other.
And then we're inventing
a lot of new notation.
And I have to rewrite
that section.
But anyway, the results are all
correct as far as I know.
I mean, all of you can remember
notation much better
than I can.
So if I can remember this
notation, you can also.
Let me put it that way.
So I can't feel too
sorry for you.
I want to rewrite it because I'm
feeling sorry for myself
after every year I go through
this and try to re-understand
it again, and I find it
very hard to do it.
So I'm going to rewrite
it and get rid of
some of that notation.
We've already seen that if you
have a chain like this, which
is simply the Markov chain
corresponding to Bernoulli
trials, if it's Bernoulli trials
with p equals 1/2, you
move up a probability
1/2, you move down
with probability 1/2.
As we said, you eventually
disperse.
And as you disperse, the
probability of being in any
one of these states goes to 0.
And what that means is that the
individual probabilities
of the states is going to 0.
You can also see, not so easily,
that you're eventually
going to return to each state
with probability 1.
And I'm sorry I didn't give
that definition first.
We gave it last time.
If the expected value of the
renewal time is less than
infinity, then j is positive
recurrent.
If T sub jj, the recurrence
time, is a random variable but
it has infinite expectation,
then j is not recurrent.
And finally, if none of those
things happen, j is transient.
So that we went through
last time.
And for p equals 1/2, and in
both of these situations, the
probability of being in any
state is going to 0.
The expected time of returning
is going to infinity.
But with probability 1, you
will return eventually.
So in both of these cases, these
are both examples of no
recurrence.
Let's say more about positive
recurrence and no recurrence.
Suppose, first, that i and j
are both recurrent and they
both communicate with
each other.
In other words, there's a path
from i to j, there's a path
from j to i.
And I want to look at
the renewal process
of returns to j.
You've sorted out by now, I
think, that recurrence means
exactly what you
think it means.
A recurrence means, starting
from a state j, there's a
recurrence to j if eventually
you come back to j.
And this random variable, the
recurrence of random variable,
is the amount of time it takes
you to get back to j once
you've been in j.
That's a random variable.
So let's look at the renewal
process, starting in j, of
returning to j eventually.
This is one of the
things that makes
this whole study awkward.
We have renewal processes when
we start at j and we bob back
to j at various periods
of time.
If we start in i and we're
interested in returns to j,
then we have something called
a delayed renewal process.
All the theorems about
renewals apply there.
It's a little harder to
see what's going on.
It's in the end of
chapter four.
You should have read it,
at least quickly.
But we're going to avoid those
theorems and instead go
directly using the theorems
of renewal processes.
But there's still places where
the transitions are awkward.
So I can warn you about that.
But the renewal reward theorem,
if I look at this
renewal process, I get a
renewal every time I
return to state j.
But in that renewal process of
returns to state j, what I'm
really interested in is returns
to state i, because
what I'm trying to do here is
relate how often do you go to
state i with how often
do you go to state j?
So we have a little bit of a
symmetry in it, because we're
starting in state j,
because that gives
us a renewal process.
But now we have this renewal
reward process, where we give
ourselves a reward of 1 every
time we hit state i.
And we have a renewal every
time we hit state j.
So how does that renewal
process work?
Well, it's a renewal process
just like every other one
we've studied.
It has this peculiar feature
here that is a discrete time
renewal process.
And with discrete time renewal
processes, as we've seen, you
can save yourself a lot of
aggravation by only looking at
these discrete times.
Namely, you only look
at integer times.
And now when you only look
at integer times--
well, whether you look at
integer times or not--
this is the fundamental theorem
of renewal rewards.
If you look at the limit as t
goes to infinity, there's the
integral of the rewards
you pick up.
For this discrete case, this
is just a summation of the
rewards that you get.
This summation here by the
theorem is equal to the
expected number of rewards
within one renewal period.
Namely, this is the expected
number of recurrences of state
i per state j.
So in between each occurrence
of state j, what's the
expected number of
i's that I hit?
And that's the number
that it is.
We don't know what that number
is, but we could calculate it
if we wanted to.
It's not a limit of anything.
Well, it's a sort of a limit,
but not very much of a limit
that's well defined.
And the theorem says that this
integral is equal to that
expected value divided by
the expected recurrence
time of T sub jj.
Now, we argue that this is,
in fact, the number of
occurrences of state i.
So it's in the limit.
It's 1 over the expected
value of the recurrence
time to state i.
So what this says is the 1 over
the recurrence time to
state i is equal to the expected
number of recurrences
to state i per state j divided
by the expected
time in state j.
If you think about that for a
minute, it's something which
is intuitively obvious.
I mean, you look at this long
sequences of things.
You keep hitting j's every
once in a while.
And then what you do,
is you count all of
the i's that occur.
So now looking at it this way,
you're going to count the
number of i's that occur
in between each j.
You can't have a simultaneous
i and j.
The state is o or j.
So for each recurrence period,
you count the number of i's
that occur.
And what this is then saying,
is the expected time between
i's is equal to the expected
time between j's divided by--
if I turn this equation upside
down, the expected time
between i's is equal to the
expected time between j's
divided by the expected
number of i's per j.
What else would you expect?
It has to be that way, right?
But this says that it
indeed, is that way.
Mathematics is sometimes
confusing with countable-state
chains as we've seen.
OK, so the theorem then says for
i and j recurrent, either
both are positive-recurrent or
both are null-recurrent.
So this is adding to the
theorem we had earlier.
The theorem we had earlier says
that all states within a
class are either recurrent
or they're transient.
This now divides the ones that
are recurrent into two
subsets, those that are
null-recurrent and those that
are positive-recurrent.
It says that for states within
a class, either all of them
are recurrent or all
of them are--
all of them are
positive-recurrent or all of
them are null-recurrent.
And this theorem shows it
because this theorem says
there has to be an expected
number of occurrences of state
i between each occurrence
of state j.
Why is that?
Because there has to be
a path from i to j.
And there has to be a path that
doesn't go through i.
Because if you have a path from
i that goes back to i and
then off to j, there's also
this path from i to j.
So there's a path from i to j.
There's a path from j to i that
does not go through i.
That has positive probability
because paths are only defined
over transitions with positive
probability.
So this quantity is always
positive if you're talking
about two states in
the same class.
So what this relationship says,
along with the fact that
it's a very nice and convenient
relationship--
I almost put it in the
quiz for finite
state and Markov chains.
And you cam be happy I didn't,
because proving it takes a
little more agility than
what one might
expect at this point.
The theorem then says that if i
and j are recurrent, either
both are positive-recurrent or
both are null-recurrent, what
the overall theorem then says
is that for every class of
states, either all of them are
transient, all of them are
null-recurrent, or all of them
are positive-recurrent.
And that's sort of a convenient
relationship.
You can't have some states
that you never get to.
Or you only get to with an
infinite recurrence time in a
class and others that you keep
coming back to all the time.
If there's a path from one to
the other, then they have to
work the same way.
This sort of makes it
obvious why that is.
And this is too sensitive.
OK.
OK , so now we want to look
at steady state for
positive-recurrent chain.
Do you remember that when we
looked at finite state in
Markov chains, we did all this
classification stuff, and then
we went into all this
matrix stuff?
And the outcome of the matrix
stuff, the most important
things, were that there
is a steady state.
There's always a set of
probabilities such that if you
start the chain in those
probabilities, the chain stays
in those probabilities.
There's always a set of pi sub
i's, which are probabilities.
They all sum to 1.
They're all non-negative.
And each of them satisfy the
relationship, the probability
that you're in state j at time
t is equal to the probability
that you're in state i at
time t minus 1 times the
probability of going
from state i to j.
This is completely familiar
from finite-state chains.
And this is exactly
the same for
countable-state and Markov chains.
The only question is, it's now
not at all sure that that
equation has a solution
anymore.
And unfortunately, you can't
use matrix theory to prove
that it has a solution.
So we have to find some
other way of doing it.
So we look in our toolbox,
which we developed
throughout the term.
And there's only one obvious
thing to try, and
it's renewal theory.
So we use renewal theory.
We then want to have one other
definition, which you'll see
throughout the rest of the term
and every time you start
reading about Markov chains.
When you read about Markov
chains in queuing kinds of
situations, which are the kinds
of things that occur all
over the place, almost all of
those Markov chains are
countable-state Markov chains.
And therefore, you need a
convenient word to talk about
a class of states where all of
the states in that class
communicate with each other.
And irreducible is the
definition that we use.
An irreducible Markov chain is
a Markov chain in which all
pairs of states communicate
with each other.
And before, when we were talking
about finite-state
Markov chains, if all states
communicated with each other,
then they were are recurrent.
You had a recurrent Markov
chain, end of story.
Now we've seen that you can have
a Markov chain where all
the states communicate
with each other.
We just had these
two examples--
these two examples here
where they all
communicate with each other.
But depending on what p and q
are, they're either transition
transient, or they're
positive-recurrent, or they're
null-recurrent.
The first one can't even be
positive-recurrent, but it can
be recurrent.
And the bottom one can also
be positive-recurrent.
So any Markov chain where all
the states communicate with
each other--
there's a path from everything
to everything else--
which is the usual situation,
is called an irreducible
Markov chain.
An irreducible can now be
positive-recurrent,
null-recurrent, or transient.
All the states in an irreducible
Markov chain have
to be transient, or all
of them have to be
positive-recurrent, or all
null-recurrent.
You can't share these
qualities over
an irreducible chain.
That's what this last
theorem just said.
OK, so if a steady
state exists--
namely if the solution to those
equations exist, and if
the probability that X sub 0
equals i is equal to pi i.
And incidentally, in the version
that got handed out,
that equation there was
a little bit garbled.
That one.
Said the probability that X sub
0 was equal to pi i, which
doesn't make any sense.
If a steady-state exists
and you start out in
steady-state--
namely, the starting state X
sub 0 is in state i with
probability pi sub i by for
every i, this is the same
trick we played for
finite-state and Markov chains.
As we go through this, I will
try to explain what's the same
and what's different.
And this is completely
the same.
So there's nothing new here.
Then, this situation of being in
steady-state persists from
one unit of time to the next.
Namely, if you start out in
steady-state, then the
probability that X sub 1 is
equal to j is equal to the sum
over i of pi sub i.
That's the probability that
X sub 0 is equal to i.
Times P sub i j, which by the
steady-state equations, is
equal to pi sub j.
So you start out in
steady-state.
After one transition, you're
in steady-state again.
You're in steady-state
at time 1.
Guess what, you're
in state time 2.
You're in steady-state again.
And you stay in steady-state
forever.
So when you iterate, the
probability that you're in
state j at time X sub n is
equal to pi sub j also.
This is assuming that you
started out in steady-state.
So again, we need some
new notation here.
Let's let N sub j of tilde be
the number of visits to j in
the period 0 to t starting
in steady-state.
Namely, if you start in state j,
we get a renewal process to
talk about the returns
to state j.
If we start in steady-state,
then this first return to
state j is going to have a
different set of probabilities
than all subsequent returns
to state j.
So N sub j of t, tilde is now
not a renewal process, but a
delayed renewal process.
So we have to deal with it
a little bit differently.
But it's a very nice thing
because for all t, the
expected number of returns to
state j over t transitions is
equal to n times pi sub j.
Pi sub j is the probability that
you will be in state j at
any time n.
And it stays the same
for every n.
So if we look at the expected
number of times we hit state
j, it's exactly equal
to n times pi sub j.
And again, here's this
awkward thing about
renewals and Markov.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So is that sort of
like an ensemble average--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Or is the time
average [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's an
ensemble average and it's a
time average.
But the thing we're working
with here is the
fact there's a time--
is the fact that it's an
ensemble average, yes.
But it's convenient
because it's an
exact ensemble average.
Usually, with renewal processes,
things are ugly
until you start getting
into the limit zone.
Here, everything is nice
and clean all the time.
So we start out in steady-state
and we get this
beautiful result.
It's starting in steady-state.
The expected number of visit
to state j by time n--
oh, this is interesting.
That t there should
be n obviously.
Well, since we have t's
everywhere else, that n there
should probably be t also.
So you can fix it whichever
way you want.
n's and t's are the same.
I mean, for the purposes of this
lecture, let all t's be
n's and let all n's be t's.
This works for some things.
This starts in steady state,
stays in steady state.
It doesn't work for renewals
because it's a delayed renewal
process, so you can't talk
about a renewal process
starting in state j, because you
don't know that it starts
in state j.
So sometimes we want
to deal with this.
Sometimes we want to
deal with this.
This is the number of returns
to t starting in state j.
to state j over 0 to t if we
start in steady-state.
Here's a useful hack, which you
can use a lot of the time.
Look at what N sub
i j of t is.
It's the number of times
you hit state j
starting in state i.
So let's look at it as you go
for while, you hit state j for
the first time.
After hitting state j for the
first time, you then go
through a number of repetitions
of state j.
But after that first time you
hit state j, you have a
renewal process starting then.
In other words, you have a
delayed renewal process up to
the first renewal.
After that, you have
all the statistics
of a renewal process.
So the idea then is N
sub i j of t is 1.
Counts 1 for the first visit
to j, if there are any.
Plus, N sub i j of t minus
1 for all the subsequent
recurrences from j to j.
Thus, when you look at the
expected values of this, the
expected value of N sub i j of
t is less than or equal to 1
for this first recurrence, for
this first visit, plus the
expected value of N sub j j of
some number smaller than t.
But N sub j j of
t grows with t.
It's a number of visits
over some interval.
And as the interval gets bigger
and bigger, the number
of visits can't shrink.
So you just put the t there
to make it an upper bound.
And then, when you look at
starting in steady-state, what
you get is the sum overall
starting states pi sub i of
the expected value of
N sub i j of t.
And this is less than or equal
to 1 plus the expected value
of N sub j j of t also.
So this says you can always get
from N tilde of t to N sub
j j of t, by just giving
up this term 1
here as an upper bound.
If you don't like that proof--
and it's not really a proof.
If you try to make it a proof,
it gets kind of ugly.
It's part of the proof of
theorem 4 in the text, which
is even more ugly.
Because it's mathematically
clean with equations, but you
don't get any idea of why it's
true from looking at it.
This you know why it's true from
looking at it, but you're
not quite sure that it satisfies
the equations that
you would like.
I am trying to move you from
being totally dependent on
equations to being more
dependent on ideas like this,
where you can see
what's going on.
But I'm also urging you, after
you see what's going on, to
have a way to put the equations
in to see that
you're absolutely
right with it.
OK, now, we come to the major
theorem of countable-state and
Markov chains.
It's sort of the crucial
thing that everything
else is based on.
I mean, everything beyond
what we've already done.
For any irreducible
Markov chain--
in other words, for any Markov
chain where all the states
communicate with each other,
the steady-state equations
have a solution if and only
if the states are
positive-recurrent.
Now, remember, either all the
states are positive-recurrent
or none of them are.
So there's nothing
confusing there.
If all the states are
positive-recurrent, then there
is a steady-state solution.
There is a solution to
those equations.
And if the set of states are
transient, or null-recurrent,
then there isn't a solution
to all those equations.
If a solution exists, then the
probability, the steady-state
probability is state i is 1 over
the main recurrence time
to state i.
This is a relationship that we
established by using renewal
theory for finite-state
and Markov chains.
We're just coming
back to it here.
One thing which is important
here is that pi sub i is
greater than 0 for all i.
This is a property we
had for finite-state
Markov chains also.
But it's a good deal more
surprising here.
When you have a countable number
of states, saying that
every one of them has a positive
probability is--
I don't think it's entirely
intuitive.
If you think about it
for a long time,
it's sort of intuitive.
But it's the kind of intuitive
thing that really pushes your
intuition into understanding
what's going on.
So let's give a Pf of this,
of the only if part.
And I will warn you
about reading the
proof in the notes.
It's ugly because it just goes
through a bunch of logical
relationships and equations.
You have no idea of where
it's going or why.
And finally, at the
end it says, QED.
I went through it.
It's correct.
But damned if I know why.
And so, anyway, that has
to be rewritten.
But, anyway here's the Pf.
Start out by assuming that the
steady-state equations exist.
We want to show
positive-recurrence.
Pick any j and any t.
Pick any state and any time.
pi sub j is equal to the
expected value of N sub j
tilde of t.
That we chose for any
Markov chain at all.
If you start out in
steady-state, you stay in
steady-state.
So under the assumption that
we're in steady-state--
under the assumption that we
start out in steady-state, we
stay in steady-state.
This pi sub j times t has to be
the expected value of the
number of recurrences to state
j over t time units.
And what we showed on
the last slide--
you must have realized I was
doing this for some reason.
This is less than or equal to 1
plus the expected recurrence
time of state j.
So pi sub j is less than or
equal to 1 over t times this
expected recurrence
time for state j.
And if we go to the limit as t
goes to infinity, this 1 over
t dribbles away to
nothingness.
So this is less than or equal to
the limit of expected value
of N sub j j of t over t.
What is that?
That's the expected number,
long-term rate of
visits to state j.
It's what we've shown as equal
to 1 over the expected renewal
time of state j.
Now, if the sum of the pi sub
j's is equal to 1, remember
what happens when you sum a
countable set of numbers.
If all of them are 0, then no
matter how many of them you
sum, you have 0.
And when you go to the limit,
you still have 0.
So when you sum a set of
countable set of non-negative
numbers, you have
to have a limit.
Because it's non-decreasing.
And that sum is equal to 1.
Then somewhere along the line,
you've got to find the
positive probability.
One of the [INAUDIBLE]
has to be positive.
I mean, this is almost an
amusing proof because you work
so hard to prove that one
of them is positive.
And then, almost for free, you
get the fact that all of them
have to be positive.
So some pi j is greater
than 0.
If pi j is less than or equal
to this, thus the limit as t
approaches infinity of the
expected value of N sub j j of
t over t is greater than 0 for
that j, which says j has to be
positive-recurrent.
Which says all the states have
to be positive-recurrent
because we've already
shown that.
So all the states are
positive-recurrent.
Then you still have to show that
this inequality here is
equality, and you've got to do
that by playing around with
summing up these things.
Something has been left
out, we have to sum
those up over j.
And that's another mess.
I'm not going to do
it here in class.
But just sort of see
why this happened.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why do you have to show
the equality?
PROFESSOR: Why do I have
to the equality?
Because if I want to show that
all of the pi sub i's are
positive, how do I show that?
All I've done is started
out with an arbitrary--
oh, I've started out with
an arbitrary j and
an arbitrary t.
Because I got the fact that this
was positive-recurrent by
arguing that at least
one of the pi sub
j's had to be positive.
From this I can argue
that they're all
positive-recurrent, which tells
me that this number is
greater than 0.
But that doesn't show me that
this number is greater than 0.
But it is.
I mean, it's all right.
It all works out.
But not quite in such a simple
way as you would hope.
OK, so now let's go back to
what we called birth-death
chains, but look at a slightly
more general version of them.
These are things that you--
I mean, queuing theory is
built on these things.
Everything in queuing theory.
Or not everything, but all the
things that come from a
Poisson kind of background.
All of these somehow look at
the birth-death chains.
And the way a birth-death
chain works is you have
arbitrary self-loops.
You have positive probabilities
going from each
state to the next state up.
You have positive probabilities
going from the
higher state to the
lower state.
All transitions are
limited from--
i can only go to i plus 1,
or i, for i minus 1.
You can't make big jumps.
You can only make jumps
of one step.
And other than that, it's
completely general.
OK, now we go through an
interesting argument.
We look at an arbitrary
state i.
And for this arbitrary state i,
like i equals 2, we look at
the number of transitions
that go from 2 to 3.
And the number transitions that
go from 3 to 2 for any
old sample path whatsoever.
And for any sample path,
the number of
transitions that go up--
if we start down there, before
you can come back,
you've got to go up.
So if you're on that side, you
have one more up transition
than you have down transition.
If you're on that side, you
have the same number of up
transitions and down
transitions.
So that as you look over a
longer and longer time, the
number of up transitions is
effectively the same as the
number of down transitions.
If you have a steady-state, pi
sub i is the fraction of time
you're in state i.
pi sub i times p sub i is the
fraction of time you're going
from state i to state
i plus 1.
And pi sub i by plus 1 times q
sub i plus 1 is the fraction
of time you're going
from state i plus 1
down to state i.
What we've just argued by the
fact that sample path averages
and ensemble averages have to
be equal is that pi sub i
times p sub i is equal to
pi sub i plus 1 times
q sub i plus 1.
In the next slide, I will
talk about whether to
believe that or not.
For the moment, let's
say we believe it.
And from this equation, we
see that the steady-state
probability of i plus 1 is
equal to the steady-state
probability of i times p sub
i over q sub i plus 1.
It says that the steady-state
probability of each pi is
determined by the steady-state
probability of the state
underneath it.
So you just go up.
You can calculate the
steady-state of each, the
probability of each if you know
the probability of the
state below it.
So if you recurse on this, pi
sub i plus 1 is equal to pi
sub i times this ratio is equal
to pi sub i minus 1
times this ratio times p sub i
minus 1 over q sub i is equal
to pi sub i minus 2 times
this triple of things.
It tells you that what you want
to do is define row sub i
as the difference of these two
probabilities, namely rob i,
for any state i, is the ratio
of that probability to that
probability.
And this equation then turns
into pi sub i plus 1 equals pi
sub i times row sub i.
If you put all those
things together--
if you just paste them one after
the other, the way I was
suggesting--
what you get is pi sub i is
equal to pi sub 0 times this
product of terms.
The product of terms looks
a little ugly.
Why don't I care about
that very much?
Well, because usually, when you
have a chain like this,
all the Ps are the same and
all the Qs are the same--
or all the Ps are the same for
some point beyond someplace,
they're are different
before that.
There's always some structure
to make life easy for you.
Oh, that's my computer.
It's telling me what
time it is.
I'm sorry.
OK.
So pi sub i is this.
We then have to calculate
pi sub 0.
Pi sub 0 is then 1 divided
by the sum of all the
probabilities is pi sub 0 times
all those other things.
It's 1 plus the sum here.
And now if you don't believe
what I did here, and I don't
blame you for being a little
bit skeptical.
If you don't believe this, then
you look at this and you
say, OK, I can now go back and
look at the steady state
equations themselves and I can
plug this into the steady
state equations themselves.
And you will immediately see
that this solution satisfies
the steady state equations.
OK.
Oh, damn.
Excuse my language.
OK.
So we have our birth-death
chain with all these
transitions here.
We have our solution to it.
Note that the solution is only
a function of these rows.
It's only a function of the
ratio of p sub i to
Q sub i plus 1.
It doesn't depend on those
self loops at all.
Isn't that peculiar?
Completely independent of what
those self loops are.
Well, you'll see later that it's
not totally independent
of it, but it's essentially
independent of it.
And you think about that for a
while and suddenly it's not
that confusing because those
equations have come from
looking at up transitions
and down transitions.
By looking at an up transition
and a down transition at one
place here, it tells you
something about the fraction
of time you're over there and
the fraction of time you're
down there if you know what
these steady state
probabilities are.
So if you think about it for a
bit, you realize that these
steady state probabilities
cannot depend that strongly on
what those self loops are.
So this all sort
of makes sense.
The next thing is the expression
for pi 0--
namely this thing here--
is a product of these terms.
It converges and therefore the
chain is positive recurrent
because there is a solution to
the steady state equation.
It converges if the
row sub i's are
asymptotically less than 1.
So for example, if
the row sub i's--
beyond i equals 100--
are bounded by, say, 0.9, then
these terms have to go to 0
rapidly after i equals 100 and
this product has to converge.
I say essentially here of all
these particular cases where
the row sub i's are very close
to 1, and they're converging
very slowly to 1
and who knows.
But for most of the things we
do, these row sub i's are
strictly less than
1 as you move up.
And it says that you have
to have steady state
probabilities.
So for most birth-death chains,
it's almost immediate
to establish whether it's
recurrent, positive recurrent,
or not positive recurrent.
And we'll talk more about that
when we get into Markov
processes, but that's enough
of it for now.
Comment on methodology.
We could check the renewal
results carefully, because
what we're doing here is
assuming something rather
peculiar about time averages
and ensemble averages.
And sometimes you have to worry
about those things, but
here, we don't have to worry
about it because we have this
major theorem which tells
us if steady state
probabilities exist--
and they exist because they
satisfy these equations--
then you have positive
recurrence.
So it says the methodology to
use is not to get involved in
any deep theory, but just
to see if these
equations are satisfied.
Again, good mathematicians
are lazy--
good engineers are
even lazier.
That's my motto of the day.
And finally, birth-death
chains are going to be
particularly useful in queuing
where the births are arrivals
and the deaths are departures.
OK.
Now we come to reversibility.
I'm glad we're coming to that
towards the end of the lecture
because reversibility is
something which I don't think
any of you guys even--
and I think this is a
pretty smart class--
but I've never seen anybody who
understands reversibility
the first time they
think about it.
It's a very peculiar concept and
the results coming from it
are peculiar, and we will have
to live with it for a while.
But let's start out with
the easy things--
just with a definition of
what a Markov chain is.
This top equation here says
that the probability of a
whole bunch of states--
X sub n plus k down to X sub n
plus 1 given the stated time,
n, down to the stated time 0.
Because of the Markov condition,
that has to be
equal to the probability
of these terms
just given X sub n.
Namely, if you know what X sub
n is, for the future, you
don't have to know what any of
those previous states are.
You get that directly from
where we started with the
Markov chains-- the probability
of X sub n plus 1,
given all this stuff, and
then you just add the
other things onto it.
Now, if you define A plus as any
event which is defined in
terms of X sub n plus 1, X of n
plus 2, and so forth up, and
if you define A minus as
anything which is a function
of X sub n minus 1, X sub n
minus 2, down to X sub 0, then
what this equations
says is that the
probability of any A plus--
given X sub n and A minus--
is equal to the probability
of A plus given X sub n.
And this hasn't gotten
hard yet.
If you think this is
hard, just wait.
If we now multiply this by
the probability of A
minus given X sub n--
and what I'm trying to get at
is, how do you reason about
the probabilities of
earlier states
given the present state?
We're used to proceeding
in time.
We're used to looking at
the past for telling
what the future is.
And every once and a while, you
want to look at the future
and predict what the
past had to be.
It's probably more important to
talk about the future given
the past, because sometimes
you don't know
what the future is.
But mathematically, you
have to sort that out.
So if we multiply this equation
by the probability of
A minus, given X sub n,
we don't know what
that is, but it exists.
It's a defined conditional
probability.
Then what we get is the
probability of A plus and A
minus, given X sub n, is equal
to the probability of A plus,
given X sub n, times the
probability of A
minus, given X sub n.
So that the probability of the
future and the past, given
what's happening now, is equal
to the probability of the
future, given what's happening
now, times the probability the
past, given what's
happening now.
Which may be a more interesting
way of looking at
past and future and present
than this totally
asymmetric way here.
This is a nice, symmetric
way of looking at it.
And as soon as you see that this
has to be true, then you
can turn around and write this
the opposite way, and you see
that the probability of A minus,
given X sub n, and A
plus is equal to the
probability of A
minus given X sub n.
Which says that the probability
of the past, given
X sub n and the future, is equal
to the probability of
the past just given X sub n.
You can go from past the future
or you can go from
future to past.
And incidentally, if you people
have trouble trying to
think of the past and
the future as
being symmetric animals--
and I do too--
everything we do with time can
also be done on a line going
from left to right, or it
can be done on a line
going from bottom up.
Going from bottom up, it's
hard to say that this is
symmetric to this.
If you look at it on a line
going from left to right, it's
kind of easy to see that this
is symmetric between left to
right and right to left.
So every time you get confused
about these arguments, put
them on a line and argue right
to left and left to right
instead of earlier and later.
Because mathematically, it's
the same thing, but it's
easier to see these
symmetries.
And now, if you think of A minus
as being X sub n minus
1, and you think of A plus as
being X sub n plus 1, X sub n
plus 2 and so forth up, what
this equation says is that the
probability of the last state
in the past, given the state
now and everything in the
future, is equal to the
probability of the last state
in the past given X sub n.
Now, this isn't reversibility.
I'm not saying that these
are special process.
This is true for any Markov
chain in the world.
These relationships
are always true.
This is one reason why many
people view this as the real
Markov condition, as opposed to
any of these other things.
They say that three events
have a Markov condition
between them if there's
one of them which is
in between the other.
Where you can say that the
probability of the left one,
given the middle one, times
the right one, given the
middle one, is equal to the
probability of the left and
the right given the middle.
It says that the past and the
future, given the present, are
independent of each other.
It says that as soon as you
know what the present is,
everything down there
is independent of
everything up there.
That's a pretty powerful
condition.
And you'll see that we can do an
awful lot with it, so it's
going to be important.
OK.
So let's go on with that.
By Bayes rule--
and incidentally, this is why
Bayes got into so much trouble
with the other statisticians
in the world.
Because the other statisticians
in the world
really got emotionally upset at
the idea of talking about
the past given the future.
That was almost an attack on
their religion as well as all
the mathematics they knew and
everything else they knew.
It was really hitting them below
the belt, so to speak.
So they didn't like this.
But now, we've recognized that
Bayes' Law is just the
consequence of the axioms of
probability, and there's
nothing strange about it.
You write down these conditional
probabilities and
that's sitting there,
facing you.
But what it says here is that
the probability of the state
at time n minus 1, given the
state of time n, is equal to
the probability of the state
of time n, given n minus 1,
times the probability of X
n minus 1 divided by the
probability of X n.
In other words, you put this
over in this side, and it says
the probability of X n times the
probability of X n minus 1
given X n is that probability
up there.
It says that the probability
of A given B times the
probability of B is equal to the
probability of A times the
probability of B given A. And
that's just the definition of
a conditional probability,
nothing more.
OK.
If the forward chain is in
a steady state, then the
probability that X sub n minus
1 equals j, given X sub n
equals i, is pji times pi sub
j divided by pi sub i.
These probabilities become
just probabilities which
depend on i but not on n.
Now what's going on here is
when you look at this
equation, it looks peculiar
because normally with a Markov
chain, we start out at time 0
with some assumed probability
distribution.
And as soon as you start out
with some assumed probability
distribution at time 0 and you
start talking about the past
condition on the future,
it gets very sticky.
Because when you talk about
the past condition on the
future, you can only go back to
time equals 0, and you know
what's happening down there
because you have some
established probabilities
at 0.
So what it says is in this
equation here, it says that
the Markov chain, defined
by this rule--
I guess I ought to back
and look at the
previous slide for that.
This is saying the probability
of the state at time n minus
1, conditional on the entire
future, is equal to the
probability of X sub n minus
1 just given X sub n.
This is the Markov condition,
but it's the Markov condition
turned around.
Usually we talk about the next
state given the previous state
and everything before that.
Here, we're talking about
the previous state given
everything after that.
So this really is the Markov
condition on what we might
view as a backward chain.
But to be a Markov chain, these
transition probabilities
have to be independent of n.
The transition probabilities
are not going to be
independent of n if you have
these arbitrary probabilities
at time 0 lousing
everything up.
So you can get around
this in two ways.
One way to get around it is
to say let's restrict our
attention to positive recurrent
processes which are
starting out in a
steady state.
And if we start out in a steady
state, then these
probabilities here--
looking at these probabilities
here--
if you go from here down to
here, you'll find out that
this does not depend on n.
And if you have an initial state
which is something other
than steady state, then these
will depend on it.
Let me put this down in
the next chain up.
The probability of X sub n minus
1 given X sub n is going
to be independent of n if this
is independent of n, which it
is, because we have a
homogeneous Markov chain.
And this is independent of n and
this is independent of n.
Now, this will just be the
probability of pi sub i if X
sub n minus 1 is equal to i.
And this will be pi sub i if
probability of X sub n is
equal to i.
So this and this will be
independent of n if in fact we
start out in a steady state.
In other words, it won't be.
So what we're doing here is we
normally think of a Markov
chain starting out at time 0
because how else can you get
it started?
And we think of it in forward
time, and then we say, well,
we want to make it homogeneous,
because we want
to make it always do the same
thing in the future otherwise
it doesn't really look much
like the a Markov chain.
So what we're saying is that
this backward chain-- we have
backward probabilities
defined now--
the backward probabilities are
homogeneous if the forward
probabilities start
in a steady state.
You could probably make a
similar statement but say the
forward probabilities are
homogeneous if the backward
probabilities start
in a steady state.
But I don't know when you're
going to start.
You're going to have to start it
sometime in the future, and
that gets too philosophical
to understand.
OK.
If we think of the chain as
starting in a steady state at
time minus infinity, these are
also the equations of the
homogeneous Markov chain.
We can start at time minus
infinity wherever we want to--
it doesn't make any
difference--
because by the time we get to
state 0, we will be in steady
state, and the whole range of
where we want to look at
things will be in
steady state.
OK.
So aside from this issue about
starting at 0 and steady state
and things like that, what we've
really shown here is
that you can look at a Markov
chain either going forward or
going backward.
Or look at it going rightward
or going leftward.
And that's really pretty
important.
OK.
That still doesn't say anything
about it being
reversible.
What reversibility is--
it comes from looking at
this equation here.
This says what the transition
probabilities are, going
backwards, and this
is the transition
probabilities going forward.
These are the steady state
probabilities.
And if we define P star of ji
as a backward transition
probabilities--
namely, the probability that at
this time or in stage A--
given that in this next time,
which to us, is the previous
time, we're in state i, is the
probability of going in a
backward direction
from j to i.
This gets into whether this is
P star of ij or P star of ij.
But I did check it carefully,
so it has to be right.
So anyway, when you substitute
this in for this, the
conditions that you get is pi
sub i times P star of ij is
equal to pi j times P of ji.
These are the same equations
that we had for
a birth-death chain.
But now, we're not talking
about birth-death chains.
Now we're talking about
any old chain.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't this only
make sense for positive
recurring chains?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Sorry.
I should keep emphasizing that,
because it only makes
sense when you can define the
steady state probabilities.
Yes.
The steady state probabilities
are necessary in order to even
define this P star of ji.
But once you have that steady
state condition, and once you
know what the steady state
probabilities are, then you
can calculate backward
probabilities, you can
calculate forward probabilities,
and this is a
very simple relationship
that they satisfy.
It makes sense because this
is a normal form.
You look at state transition
probabilities and you look at
the probability of being in
one state and then the
probability of going
to the next state.
And the question is the
next state back there
or is it over there?
And if it's a star, then it
means it's back there.
And then we define a chain as
being reversible if P star of
ij is equal to P sub ij,
for all i and all j.
And what that means is that
all birth-death chains are
reversible.
And now let me show you
what that means.
If we look at arrivals and
departures for a birth-death
change, sometimes you go in a
self loop, so you don't go up
and you don't go down.
Other times you either
go down or you go up.
We have arrivals coming in.
Arrivals correspond to upper
transitions, departures
correspond to downward
transitions so that when you
look at it in a normal way,
you start out at time 0.
You're in state 0.
You have an arrival.
Nothing happens for a while.
You have another arrival, but
this time, you have a
departure, you have another
departure, and you wind up in
state 0 again.
As far states are concerned,
you go from
state 0 to state 1.
You stay in state 1.
In other words, this is the
difference between arrivals
and departures.
This is what the state is.
You stay in state 1.
Then you go up and you get
another arrival, you get a
departure, and then you
get a departure,
according to this chain.
Now, let's look at it
coming in this way.
When we look at it
coming backwards
in time, what happens?
We're going along here,
we're in state 0,
suddenly we move up.
If we want to view this as a
backward moving Markov chain,
this corresponds to an
arrival of something.
This corresponds to
another arrival.
This corresponds
to a departure.
We go along here with nothing
else happening, we get another
departure, and there we are back
in a steady state again.
And for any birth-death
chain, we can do this.
Because any birth-death chain
we can look at as an arrival
and departure process.
We have arrivals, we
have departures--
we might have states
that go negative.
That would be rather awkward,
but we can have that.
But now, if we know that these
steady state probabilities
govern the probability of
arrivals and the probabilities
of departures, if we know that
we have reversibility, then
these events here have the
same probability as these
events here.
It means that when we look at
things going from right back
to left, it means that the
things that we viewed as
departures here look
like arrivals.
And what we're going to do next
time is use that to prove
Burke's Theorem, which says
using this idea that if you
look at the process of
departures in a birth-death
chain where arrivals are all
with probability P and
departures are all with
probability Q, then you get
this nice set of probabilities
for arrivals and departures.
Arrivals are independent
of everything else--
same probability at every
unit of time.
Departures are the same way.
But when you're looking from
left to right, you can only
get departures when your state
is greater than 0.
When you're coming in looking
this way, these things that
looked like departures before
are looking like arrivals.
These arrivals form a Bernoulli
Process, and the
Bernoulli Process says that
given the future, the
probability of a departure,
at any instant of time, is
independent of everything
in the future.
Now, that is not intuitive.
If you think it's intuitive,
go back and think again.
Because it's not.
But anyway, I'm going
to stop here.
You have this to mull over.
We will try to sort it out
a little more next time.
This is something that's going
to take your cooperation to
sort it out, also.